how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have some really major news in
regards to the MCU thanks to some leaked
photos that came out yesterday photos
that have gave us a little bit more
information about the Wan Division
Series coming to Disney Plus and the
same photos have officially confirmed
that sword is coming to the MCU and we
have confirmation that Katherine Hans
character is definitely going to be
Agatha Harkness now of course for those
of you who do not know I will explain
what sort is but first let's go back to
the post credit scene for spider-man far
from home not the one where his identity
is revealed but the one where Nick Fury
is in space I did a video on this right
after spider-man far from home came out
because this appeared to be the
headquarters for sword and now it seems
like that is confirmed by these new
leaked photos that we have and
especially because we found out that in
the Winter Soldier when it looked like
Nick Fury died but he really didn't it
was actually Talos that came back and
was playing Nick Fury this whole entire
time so what was the real Nick Fury up
to well we learned in the spider-man far
from home post credits scene that he was
in space and now we know what he's been
doing this whole entire time he's been
building an establishing sword so let's
talk about these leaked photos from one
division and talk about sword and what
it means for the future of the MCU real
quick don't forget to subscribe when
notifications turned on like and comment
on the video so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 the winner gets to choose I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers so first one
of the most exciting leaked photos that
we have today is of Kathryn Hahn and
elizabeth Olsen now it's been confirmed
by Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios himself that Jurina the one
division series Wanda is officially
going to be called The Scarlet Witch and
if you look at some of these leaked
photos they definitely have a witch
Witchcraft type of style to them and we
can see here Kathryn Hans character
dressed up as a witch but we can also
see Elizabeth Olsen's character Wanda
dressed up as a witch as well so as we
can see here she is definitely going to
take on the mantle and the name The
Scarlet Witch and these photos
definitely confirm that Kathryn Hahn is
going to be playing Agatha Harkness
which has been a rumor to be the case
for some time now but
these photos definitely prove it and
what we're most likely looking at here
in these photos is the Salem witch
trials or New Salem now in the comics
Agatha Harkness is of course a witch and
she's depicted as one of the original
witches from the Salem witch trials in
Massachusetts she somehow survives the
Salem witch trials and then she goes on
to New Salem Colorado now in the comics
eventually Agatha Harkness would go on
to become the mentor for the Scarlet
Witch so that's what we're seeing here
Agatha Harkness is finally going to meet
the Scarlet Witch and train her in magic
and according to a recent plot leaked
about the one division series Agatha
Harkness is going to be the one that
creates this different alternate reality
in which vision is alive and the Scarlet
Witch has two children but one of the
most exciting things about Agatha
Harkness entering the MCU is that at one
point in time in the comics she was the
nanny for Franklin Richards Franklin
Richards is one of the most powerful
mutants in Marvel history Franklin of
course is the son of Reed Richards or
mr. fantastic and Sue Storm or The
Invisible Woman from the Fantastic Four
now Kevin Feige has mentioned the
Fantastic Four which means they should
be coming soon so Agatha Harkness
showing up in the MCU as well means that
we're not too far away from the
Fantastic Four entry so the reveal of
Agatha Harkness coming to the Wanda
vision series is one of the best reveals
we got from these photos but of course
like I mentioned sword has also been
revealed and officially confirmed
we have leaked photos of tiana parros's
Monica Rambeau which I'll talk about in
just a little bit but in one of the
photos we can see a sword agent was
sword literally across his vest and the
sword logo in the background and this is
a photo directly from the set of the one
division series so sword has officially
been confirmed to be heading to the MCU
during the one division series
now sword stands for sentient world
observation and response department now
swords job is to deal with
extraterrestrial or alien threats to
world security and is a space-based
counterpart to shield whose job is to
deal with local threats to the world and
what's really awesome about sword
entering the MCU is that sword mostly
deals with and is actually ran by x-men
or mutants sword was first introduced
in astonishing x-men vol 3 number 6 and
in the comics after Nick Fury sword is
ran by Abigail brand who is a mutant
herself so the introduction of sword
means that we are definitely getting
closer to the introduction of mutants in
the MCU it's been said that the one
division series is going to be a very
weird show coming to the MCU and Disney
Plus and that is in no way a bad thing
and now it's looking like it is going to
be weird just because of all of the
different components coming to the show
because on one side we have leaked
photos of Agatha Harkness during the
Salem witch trials and then on the other
side we have leaked photos of sword so
how do the two of them connect together
in one TV series well based off of what
we know we know that half of the show is
going to take place back in time in the
early 1950s 60s and 70s and the rest of
the time is going to take place during
the present time in the MCU now Agatha
Harkness
tying into the one division series is
pretty easy to connect a dodj she's
clearly going to be Wanda's mentor at
some point in time teaching her how to
use magic and like I stated she is
probably the one that creates this new
alternate reality for Wanda giving her
everything that she wants vision back to
life and her two kids and her perfect
family in the suburbs but how to sword
come into play in this magical series
coming to Disney Plus as I mentioned in
the comics swords job is to focus on
extraterrestrial threats not earthbound
threats that's a job for shield so what
could they be doing in this series well
of course this is the Marvel Cinematic
Universe all of the Disney Plus shows
are going to take place inside of the
MCU so everything connects and of course
the MCU isn't just a repeat of what
happens in the comics of course they
changed things but they could be taking
a play from the sword ongoing series
that happened in 2009 during this series
the heads of sword are persuaded to pass
a legislation to have all aliens
currently living on earth deported from
the planet now this isn't going to be
the case in the MCU because it clearly
seems like Nick Fury is in charge of
sword and he himself has already put
scroll in disguise on earth and as we
saw in the spider-man far from home
post-credits scene there are a ton of
scroll on the swords headquarters the
peak so it doesn't seem like they're
going to be getting rid of any aliens
anytime soon how
what could happen is they could start to
track down threats that are supernatural
it's already been confirmed that Wanda
is basically the strongest Avenger she
almost killed Thanos by herself in fact
the Risa brothers have confirmed that if
Thanos didn't train fire she would have
killed him but Wanda doesn't exactly
have the best track record with earth in
the beginning of age of Ultron where her
and Quicksilver were introduced they
worked with Ultron and they messed up
the Avengers pretty badly so shield
definitely knows who they are even
though technically there was no shield
at that time and then we go to Captain
America's Civil War in Lagos where Wanda
ends up killing several wakandan
humanitarian workers on accident so
she's definitely on the radar of shield
and probably sword as some type of
supernatural extraterrestrial being so
one thing that could happen that could
bring sword to be involved in the one
division series is that the Scarlet
Witch could lose control and sword could
decide that beans like this supernatural
beans could not be good for Earth we
basically kind of know what's going to
happen during the one division series
whether it's created by Wanda herself
Agatha Harkness nightmare or any other
possibility we know that Wanda is going
to end up in an alternate reality
created to be her perfect world in this
reality vision is going to be alive
she's going to have kids she's going to
have a house and the suburbs is going to
be based in the 1950s and she's going to
have this perfect little family this is
her perfect dream world however sadly
it's not going to last
Wanda has a history of going insane in
the comics and through whatever means be
it Agatha Harkness or nightmare or
another factor messing up her dream
reality it's going to eventually explode
Wanda is going to eventually realize
that this dream reality that she's been
living in isn't real she's going to
realize that vision is dead and she
doesn't have kids and will most likely
get a house of M situation here where
basically Wanda goes insane and when you
have one of the most powerful beans and
the universe go insane that's typically
not too good so this could be where
sword comes into play they could be
worried about Wanda and they could be
the ones that try and maintain her so
shield could be in charge of the earthly
threats like terrorists and etc and in
the MCU sword could be in charge of the
soup
natural threats and threats like the
mutants because this is a great way to
bring in the mutants as well they could
show that sword this whole entire time
in the MCU has been monitoring mutants
this would explain why we never heard
the words mutants or x-men before in the
MCU all of this time because Nick Fury
Agent Coulson and shield were
responsible for focusing on earthly
threats and sword was responsible for
the supernatural threats like mutants
they could have existed in the MCU this
whole entire time but sword was the ones
who were dealing with them and we just
never got introduced to it and this also
makes sense based on some other leaked
photos that I'll link down below I don't
have the copyrights to use them in this
video but there are leaked photos of
Monica Rambeau grown up and we also know
that kat dennings character darcy is
going to be in the show as well so how
do these two connect to Wanda well Darcy
worked with dr. Erik Selvig and she
studied the Infinity stones specifically
the mine stone because we know that dr.
Erik Selvig has had his run-ins with the
mine stone and the mine stone is what
gave Scarlet Witch her powers so perhaps
when Wanda eventually ends up exploding
she'll be working with sword and shield
to try and help Wanda because she got
her powers from the stone which Darcy
should have knowledge about and as far
as how Monica Rambeau is connected we
know that her mother Maria Rambo was a
pilot in the Air Force and we know that
she looks up to and is close with
Captain Marvel and we know in Captain
Marvel she was exposed to the scroll and
at the end of the movie she was eating
dinner with the scroll and with Nick
Fury so as she grew up she most
definitely had connections because she
knew Nick Fury so she probably goes on
to work for shield or sword and when
Wanda probably starts to have some
problems she probably gets called in and
this makes a lot of sense because in the
comics she gets her powers from an extra
dimensional energy and that sounds a lot
like some type of energy that Wanda
could create while making an alternate
reality so perhaps this is how Monica
Rambeau could get her powers in the one
division series by Wanda so as you can
see a lot has come from these leaked
photos from the set of Wanda vision
Agatha Harkness and sword have
officially been confirmed for the series
and the MCU so be sure to let me know
what you think in the comments down
below
let me know how you think sword ties
and be sure to leave a like on this
video and subscribe with notifications
turned on so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
winner gets to decide I'm choosing a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers don't forget to
click the link in the description down
below for your chance to win an Infinity
Gauntlet and don't forget to use code
cosmic at G feel calm for 30% off G fuel
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof-woof